okay here we are on overtime max with
the government issuing guidelines for
driverless cars should we embracing this
new embracing this new technology be
wary of it why why did why do you know
about this well basically because
there's a national security aspect to
that if it can be automatic it can be
hacked oh so I don't know about you but
I dread the idea that one day somebody
hacks all of our driverless cars at once
and kills more Americans in one day than
911 which is something we need to be
wary of oh my god just when I thought it
was sleep tight everybody office worse
than a trump presidency there it is if
it's automatic it could be here that's
to worry about yeah that is very no I
love how max can just turn anything into
like a zombie apocalypse called neurosis
yeah Lonnie it whether or not Trump wins
is the Republican Party forever changed
I don't know that it is I've always
thought of this as kind of a a temporary
correction to be honest with you I think
after this election is over though the
Republican Party does have some
soul-searching to do but but to say it's
permanently changed it implies that I
think this guy actually will have some
permanent influence on how we think
about the world and I from a perspective
of someone who hopes that isn't true I
hope it isn't true but you know you know
it'll be an interesting discussion after
but isn't the problem there voters I
mean they didn't want Trump
a lot of them and we see a lot of these
Vichy Republicans who go along because
they don't want to upset the apple you
know better they know better they know
where their bread is buttered and where
their voters are but I mean you can get
rid of a Trump you can't get rid of the
voters that's who they well but but but
that means that the Republican Party
should be doing what it's always done
which is expanding its appeal to more
people and to have a message that
expands but that's not what the base
wants debate well but your horrible the
there
I think thank you mother
the bass is definitely feeding on so you
just said the some percentage of the
basses that's fair but you know I we
have to be clear to not to over
generalize I think I think that there I
think that there is some percentage of
the bass that might feel that way but I
also think that there are a lot of
Republicans who are trying to figure out
you know what does this all mean and and
I think we have to have a conversation
about expanding the party which is what
we tried to do theoretically after 2012
and now I think we're gonna have to lose
another presidential election to learn a
lesson we should have learned after
losing what last year with your family
when like you have these discussions
with your brother and then is there a
point we just go okay let's talk about
something else hmm
well I try to make it seem line hearted
in the column but actually can get
pretty tests and when I was covering w
um my older brother said to me you know
if there was a hurricane you would blame
it on Bush there was a hurricane and I
blended yeah because it was enough yeah
Capri and I he write it up so but like
when it's your family okay I mean you
can't change your family and you love
your family no matter what but like I
never understood like Matlin and
Carville like I never understood people
who could marry someone hmm who's in the
other party because I feel like politics
is an extension of your morality that
feels like that this time for sure all
right the kids right you have I mean the
difference is between these two
candidates that kind of way Trump is
about so many American I've read
articles about married couples with the
husband usually of course the guy is
voting for Trump and the woman and it's
like literally causing a rift in the
marriage and and I can understand that I
get that to me that would be a real deal
breaker you know but there have been
moments when certain Republicans have
stood up for doing the right thing
remember when that woman said Obama's an
Arab and McCain said oh no he found his
soul right and then Powell got even
better and said yeah and what if he was
a Muslim is there something wrong with
you know there are times there was a
time when the Republican Party jettison
the John Birch Society sure who said
foreigners get out and they said ah
right that's an American and we're not
going if that means losing you we lose
you parties do that the Democrats lost
the south because they said no no salute
no more segregation you know this is the
chance this is the chance for you guys
who sleep in Reagan underoos 2:7 you
remind me I have to get a new pair so
there you go this is this is the chance
do it it's going in our way Ted Cruz
today you know but is there a lot yeah
but that bad it's gonna be really hard
for the Republican Party to invite more
people in I Trump right through and just
we get that shot a bullet through every
single person gets out there brags yeah
I completely get that but you know what
but you know what it's it's it's not a
cause that I want to give up on I don't
I don't think it's a cause that I think
there are some people that really are
committed to this and we'll have to see
what happens it might be the case that
the Republican Party you know is never
the same and I mean yeah when I was a
kid we could win only the wind yeah well
not forget that right hey fun when you
could win which is why a protest vote
doesn't matter because a a protest is
only as good as much progress that's
just tell me yeah this won't vote until
he says you're not leaving here till
you're voting victory
[Applause]
protest events Johnson st. yeah you know
other people but why we all admitted to
him why don't we all admit if there was
a total whack-job lefty running as the
Democrat Anthony Weiner writing we have
any Weiner white running we get our
credit I did vote against him I'm a
[ __ ] pirate our dough is gold Powell
on one side and Anthony Weiner on the
other side side well or MIT run for MIT
Romney I vote for Romney over we write
because yeah I would too
okay so we all we're willing to go there
but you with us
well the problem
[Applause]
Hilary Clinton's new : power enough
Asian Americans on earth we don't want
to alienate this is her car this is a
quota for the year we're done okay but
we're not with your maker with it how
did you make it
will there be repercussions for our food
system as a result of the bayer monsanto
merger oh not since the Hitler Stalin
pact applauded a merger like that this
is a big one and this is one of those
headlines that nobody talks about what
happened was since for 12,000 years
farmers have banked a little bit of
their seeds every year to replant then
Monsanto came along and said no no these
seeds are intellectual property like
iPhones you need to buy new seeds every
planting season they control 90% of our
soybeans 80% of our corn which isn't
everything
that's bad enough and now we are giving
the control of our food supply to a
foreign power the Germans who could very
easily legally sell it to China who
could blackmail us with a food embargo
the same way the orders in the 1970s and
that mr. Z like us oh boy
thanks for coming on
it's a smile I agree with you now your
side breathing and what's even worse is
that when bear brought bought the
Monsanto they had to borrow a ton of
money to do it and so now I've got this
company who's broke who's got to make
back all this money they're gonna do
everything they can to make sure that no
GMO legislation is passed America you
think before when their spelling
spending millions of dollars they're
gonna spend billions of dollars now to
make sure that that doesn't happen
okay Obama's got six shows we have six
shows left to do and then no more racism
what it what are you or Crime you think
he'll do it I think he's gonna come on
this show I I'm I'm losing hope my big
supporters of getting Obama on the show
what what is it great understand how you
lost up to bear gorilla son Anthony
Bourdain that's embarrass everybody that
girl with a green lipstick right what do
you think it is maybe it's the Anthony
Weiner jokes it's because they're tame
and safe bang those grouped thank you
everybody
we'll see you next week
[Applause]